and finally new rule Melania Trump must
do what dozens of buildings around the
world have done and take the Trump name
off so far so far over a dozen
Republican candidates tried to stop
Trump and couldn't Hillary couldn't
never Trump errs couldn't muller
couldn't is there anyone left who can
check Donald Trump yes
Melania it's not anti-feminists to say
that in addition to doing everything men
can do intellectually women also have
another power the power of the ultimatum
getting men to change their destructive
ways by threatening to leave them
humiliate them or cut them off in bed
it's a tale as old as time in the
ancient Greek play Lysistrata women and
a war by denying sex to their men it was
the original Bush Doctrine
Melania the world needs you
president Hellboy has proved to be
impervious to facts reason shame and the
law but maybe if you left him for
another man especially if that man was
Mexican
maybe he would implode on his own maybe
it falls to you now Melania you can end
this reign of terror and all you have to
do is channel your inner Taylor Swift
and walk out the door you know you wanna
your unhappiness is obvious you despised
his creepy little monkey fingers
touching your hand so kick him to the
curb slap away that hand for good no
more public embarrassment no more porn
stars no more stealing your makeup toss
his boxy clown suits on the front lawn
just tell him I'm leaving you and I'm
taking our child he would be stunned we
have a child
[Applause]
yeah I know I'm probably dreaming and
Milani isn't gonna do any of this but
what if she had someone to do it with
divorce is always easier in pairs what
if you had a buddy Milania because
there's another former model who's also
married to a super-rich Republican
monster mrs. Rupert Murdoch Jerry all
and you two have a lot in common your
husbands are ruining the world Jerry
you're married to the man who runs Fox
News you're married to the man who made
brexit happen the man who got trump
elected and keeps his base ignorant the
man who killed Australia's carbon tax I
know he's rich but is it worth Western
civilization you used to be married to
Mick Jagger and now you're married to a
guy who looks like Keith Richards let
himself go
you went from start me up to make a dead
man come
from jumping jack flash to a guy with
gas gas gas
Gerry you left Mick because he was
[ __ ] everything that moved but
Rupert's [ __ ] the whole planet the
axis of evil in the world now is Trump
and Fox News we have a government
propaganda channel now it's impossible
to even tell who's wearing the head in
this horse costume
Trump here's some de monstrously false
nonsense from some crank guests on Fox
and tweets it out as fact or he gets a
brain for it and bilges it out at a
rally and Fox backs that up there on
this insane feedback loop don't like
that couple that keeps giving each other
herpes
[Applause]
so girls you got a step up we have tried
everything but the more we resist these
two menaces the stronger they get
they're like the night king in Game of
Thrones
only instead of commanding an army of
brain-dead zombies okay they're exactly
like
[Applause]
but I'm telling you cavemen like Trump
and Murdock can't handle one thing an
ego lashing Rupert has been married four
times
Trump three some guys just can't be
alone it's like how some guys get used
to being in prison they can't make it on
the outside they need to be married
when you're Donald Trump wives don't
leave you you leave them he would fall
apart if she ever said Donald there's
nothing keeping me here I can't love
what you have become and I found where
you hid my passport
[Applause]
imagine how nuts he would go if he had
to see her in the press all the time the
Trump divorce how Melania lost 200
pounds of flab
milania better than ever says I've never
felt more not dead inside Melania Oscar
De La Hoya best sex I ever had
[Applause]
you